2023 marks 10 years of the last of us
being in our lives and to celebrate
early Naughty Dog provided a small
update for its Standalone factions
multiplayer game which is set in The
Last of Us Universe in a new blog post
the developer said quote the project is
shaping up to be a fresh new experience
from our studio but one rooted in
naughty dog's passion for delivering
incredible stories characters and
gameplay alongside this small update
Naughty Dog also shared a piece of
beautiful concept art that features a
massive Shipwrecked cruise that seems to
have broken through a stone wall there
are also two figures approaching the
ship both appearing to look like
soldiers whether this concept art is a
hint at a multiplayer map remains to be
seen the blog post includes other
details such as a reconfirmation that
The Last of Us Part One will be coming
to PC on March 3rd with specs to come
later and if that PC game excites you
then how about some free ones that's
gotta be more exciting right Amazon
Prime members can claim six games this
month with the Highlight being The Evil
Within 2. this sequel to The Evil Within
is developed by Tango Gameworks and was
released in 2017. the survival horror
game follows a detective named Sebastian
Castellanos who's searching for his
daughter Lily and suffering from all the
crazy things he saw in the first game if
you don't want to raise your heartbeat
but instead want to chill out a bit
Prime gaming is also offering lawn
mowing Simulator the title conveys
exactly what you'll be doing but don't
knock it before you try it lawn mowing
Sim is perfect for just turning off your
brain and zoning out to the sound of the
grass being cut the remaining four games
in the lineup are lesser known but
feature a wide variety of genres B cop
has a retro pixel art style and chicken
police is a Noir Adventure game while
breath Edge is a space survival title
and continuing this PC Trend Nvidia
announced that the 4070 tie will be
available on January 5th and will retail
at 790 nine dollars according to Nvidia
the RTX 4070 tie is up to three times
faster than the RTX 3090 tie while using
less power like its more expensive
relatives the RTX 4070 tie is capable of
running at over 120 frames per second at
1440p its memory size is smaller with 12
gigs compared to the 4090s 24 gigs and
the 4080s 16. Nvidia also promises that
the gpu's Dual AV encoders will help cut
rendering time for video editors with up
to two times video export speed this is
perfect timing because one thing that I
want to do this year is to kind of
revamp my PC setup maybe build something
from scratch and maybe this 4070 is
exactly what I need let me know in the
comments What GPU you're using right now
I'm still on a 2060 and I'll see you
tomorrow
thank you